élèves et professeurs du lycée de johan
micoud témoin il se passe quelque chose
de très étrange partout dans votre lycée
certains de nos élèves se sont mis à
attaquer tout le monde sans aucune
raison alors je vous en prie mettez-vous
vite à l'abri en lieu sûr
c'est un écrin pour nissan
désormais les zombies tu t'es cru dans
un film c'est ce qui se passe ici
le prof de science aaas qui paraît sur
un gène ikke
doit attendre l'arrivée des secours et
si personne ne vient jamais
toi tu crois qu'ils attendent qu'on nous
sauve c'est le mieux qu'on puisse faire
je suis seul à avoir super envie de
pisser
juste ici
notre pays n'avait pas connu la loi
martiale depuis plus de 40 ans depuis le
mouvement pour la démocratisation du 18
mai 1980 la voie libre à de fausses
informations concernant l'épidémie qui
frappe ursanne sont difficiles voire
impossibles à contenir
les russes sans débat
pour évoluer par lui-même on n'y
comprend rien
comment pourrait-on trouver que les
humains sont beaux
alors que tout le monde a vu ce qu'il y
avait de pire j'intervienne
[Applaudissements]